[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben ich stehe grafenegg
küche es ist sonntags und wir haben
nicht angekauft so ist wir haben nicht
zum kühlschrank und ist das denn
wirklich so hat man denn wirklich nicht
im kühlschrank danny kent dass er
manchmal sitzt man da und denkt sich was
koche ich heute ich habe einfach nichts
dann bestelle ich meine pizza und ich
bestelle einfach keine bitten weil wir
durch den umzug sucht die pizza bestellt
haben immer weil wir keine küche das so
viel zu viel und ich weiß da würde ich
gerne pizza bestellen haben sein aber
wir gehen jetzt mal gucken was wir noch
so anrichten da haben und danach sich
mit irgendetwas einfallen dann ganz von
kleines video und ich nehme euch jetzt
mal mit sagt kessel zum kühlschrank
station 1 so was gibt der kühlschrank
her müssen wir überlegen habe ich
irgendwann zum backen da also habe ich
immer da genauso wie butter ich mache
auf jeden fall eine mehlschwitze ich
mach irgendetwas mit soße irgendwas
saucen artikel über keine pizza
bestellen gleich nämlich noch frischkäse
dazu ist überlege ich mir gleich
ich habe schon eine idee naja haben wir
nur zwei eier ich auch 24 stück ok nimmt
erstmal das und dann gehe ich noch mal
wir haben ja auch noch ein tiefkühlfach
ich habe ja immer total gern
tiefkühlgemüse aber nicht einkaufen
waren habe ich nur fischstäbchen die
gibt's nicht und ärzten sind immer gut
so ich mache jetzt auf jeden fall eine
soße auf milchbasis ist nämlich immer
ganz gerne statt sahne bei sahne inso
sind also schmeckt gut aber man hat das
gefühl man nimmt vor die kalorienbombe
zu sich und ich mache jetzt erstmal die
soße bzw ich überlege jetzt schon was
nämlich als beilage zur sauce reis oder
kartoffeln haben so darf entscheiden
kartoffeln okay bei kartoffeln habe ich
da genauso wie reift dann wobei reis
geht 5 nun schneller denn immerhin reist
ein moment jetzt habe ich hier den
basmatireis ich nehme immer einzelne
taste für hamza und milch das reicht
dann aber ganz gesund sagt auch für
nächsten tag nichts übrig und das
allerwichtigste wird an reis kochen gibt
es denn ein sieg und dann einmal unter
kaltem wasser komplett ausspülen ist das
wasser klar wieder rauskommt damit die
ganze stärke weg ist und nichts mehr
kleben bleibt
so die stärke des komplett raus gespielt
das heißt die reise kann später nicht
mehr kleben und ich mache das typische
art eigentlich kommt noch schäden also
nudeln rein
den fanden auf arabisch ariel deswegen
dazu charlie und auf türkisch oder so so
genau dann wenn wir uns noch dünne faden
not ist und die werden jetzt erstmal
frittiert also ich nehme jetzt einfach
hier schon mal etwas rapsöl rein in die
pfanne dass der boden bedeckt ist und
dann so zwei drei esslöffel von den
schaden den rhein
das hat jetzt keine minute gedauert die
nudeln sind goldbraun jetzt geben wir
den reis dazu und dünsten den halle
minuten mit an
[Musik]
das ganze noch mittlerer stufe sonst
klebt am topfboden und das ist voll
ärgerlich und jetzt geben wir wasser
dazu ich nehme für eine tasse reißt
keine zwei tassen wasser sondern ein
anteil dann erkläre das einfach nicht
und wird schön locker ich umwelt noch
eine halbe tasse und dass es einmal
aufkochen
[Musik]
so das wasser kocht und jetzt unbedingt
schon seiten ich gebe da so einigten
ganzen teelöffel sondern so ein bisschen
gesagt man jetzt fällt mir das nicht ein
auf jeden fall kein berg voll sondern
ein bisschen und dann gebe ich das noch
mit dazu
früher das gut um jetzt ist es ganz
wichtig wir nehmen eine niedrige stufe
und lassen es mit geschlossenen 6 15 bis
18 minuten lang jahren
ich nehme mir zum beispiel stufe 3 von 9
dann müsste dann je nach herd einfach
entscheiden
deckel drauf und im nächsten schritt
kümmern wir uns um alles weitere und ich
bin jetzt hier ein topf voll wasser das
er schon vorbereitet wo einmal kochen
lassen und dann die eier darin ungefähr
neun bis zehn minuten lang richtig schön
hart kochen
und jetzt gibt's an die soße und zwar
gezielt zuallererst eine mehlschwitze
gebe zum vormarsch anlocken rein wir
können auch ganz normale zwiebel nehmen
oder frühlingszwiebeln ist gar kein
thema hat sich hier erst mal die butter
wichtig ist dass er die mittlere stufe
nimmt denn butter kann sehr schnell
verbrennen und dann könnt ihr alles
wieder von vorn beginnen deshalb einfach
nur schmelzen lassen und dann die
zwiebeln dazu geben
[Musik]
zwiebeln sind glasig angedünstet so
sicher zwei minuten
und jetzt kommt das medien zu machen
eine mehlschwitze damit die soße später
richtig schön selig wird und hat nicht
zu flüssig gemacht dass du nicht immer
so ein esslöffel butter und 2 ist für
medien derart und das nähen lässt sie
ganz schön aufschäumen und rührt das gut
um so und jedes stückchen weise die
milch dazugeben aber immer nur wirklich
stückchenweise und dann gut umrühren
[Musik]
das waren jetzt ungefähr 100 milliliter
aber ich steigere mich jetzt hoch so bis
zu 300
ja ja sie ist du und pizza ganz ehrlich
bist du hier anstellten ist er da ist
nichts fertig
und jetzt kommt ein bisschen geschmack
und farbe ins spiel denn so weit darf
diese nicht bleiben nämlich zuallererst
ein paar gewürze und da guckt ja einfach
nach geschmack ich mag immer soßen mit
curry total gerne weshalb also könig auf
der mini fehlen dann nehme ich dazu
immer gern pokémon es gibt noch mal so
eine richtig hübsche farbe ab natürlich
salz und pfeffer also ein bisschen zu
viel
natürlich sei es am käfer aber völker
gebe ich gern noch zum schluss noch mal
rein zum abschmecken
so und dann habe ich hier noch rosmarin
finde ich auch mal total lecker so
natürlich abschmecken
was wir hier fabriziert haben perfekt
dafür gar nichts mehr
ich werde euch natürlich die ganzen
mengenangaben und zutaten wie unten in
die infobox schreiben also einmal
aufklappen die dann eventuell einkaufen
gehen oder nicht einkaufen gehen ich
hatte ja auch als zu hause
so und jetzt gebe ich mir noch ärzten
rein
so die ersten brauchen jetzt auch fünf
minuten in der soße und auch nur auf
niedriger stufe immer wieder umrühren
damit sich da unten nichts anbrennen
kann wir geben dem anderen keine chance
und die eier sind fertig der reis
übrigens auch arbeit komme ich jetzt
erst die eier und werde jetzt erstmal
abschrecken unter kaltem wasser die eier
habe ich das gefühl ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen haben sind hier zu leben
ich mag sie lieber wachsweich ich mag
die total gern ich jetzt immer gern
flüssiger eier haben sie überhaupt nicht
deswegen mussten sie jetzt komplett
einmal so richtig richtig kochen aber
natürlich wie ihr möchtet dann könnt ihr
das zu hause machen und die gebe ich
jetzt nur dazu und danach sich das 23
minuten 10 in der soße und dann sehe ich
alles und noch einmal ganz kurz zum
reiss das ist wenn der türkischen küche
japanischen handel vor mir habe so
übliche wollen keinen fall nachlässig
noch mal butter rhein zu geben das müsst
ihr nicht tun ist könnt ihr aber das
habe ich hier schon gemacht und dann
dass ich das immer so schmelzen in der
sitzung geht es hier noch und dann ganz
einfach umrühren hinter mir ich mir auf
meinem lieblingssänger ich finde ihn so
hübsch so und jetzt einmal den reis
stört ihn das sieht mein teller und das
ist hansa steller hätte schon mal neben
größenunterschied ich mache mir immer
kleine teller ich weiß nicht warum ich
hasse das riesentalent zu essen da und
jetzt einmal ihr müsst euch vorstellen
leute wir sind hier ganz frisch
eingezogen und ich habe noch nicht alles
blieben deswegen habe ich jetzt auch
keine schöpfkelle oder so manches
einfach mit einem drittel
und deswegen haben auch nicht im
kühlschrank dass wir immer bescheid ist
[Musik]
am besten das ist auch das gleiche aber
es ist aber schön aus als hätte ich den
noch an denn hier immer gerühmt gerade
hinter den kulissen die kamera aber
ausgestellt haben uns überlegt wir
probieren jetzt immer an unserem text
die table kann man mal wieder sagen oder
und der gehört zum probieren
[Musik]
diethelm
so enthält auf dem table haben mit
löffel übrigen habe ich mir alles
[Musik]
richtig mir fehlt auch kein fleisch oder
irgendwas und er reist richtig locker
stimmt das englische sprache konnte ich
mich gut also finde es auch gut dass
mich als kompliment also ich wollte das
ganze schnell nachmachen die gesagt noch
in der unten in der infobox wir
verabschieden uns und vielleicht könnt
ihr unserer stadt auf euch dieses format
gefallen hat ob wir vielleicht noch
sondern möchte dann kauft man in zukunft
auch wenig ein
[Musik]